hello buenas tardes de guanajuato i'm in
mexico guanajuato mexico i just want to
announce that we have our meetup on
saturday the 9th in mexico city
julio has arranged it the details are
uh
here aki ariba panera ponellas
i want to talk a little bit about mexico
i'm in our b and b here in guanajuato
i have a lot of video that i've taken
in san miguel de allende and here in
guanajuato guanajuato
um
some of it's better than others i'm
going to have to edit some of it maybe
on saturday in mexico city and i'll try
and put some of it up
i'm having a phenomenal time learning
about mexico
uh getting to know mexican people who
are extremely friendly
um and you'll see in the video uh what
the san miguel de allende is like
semigal is more of almost i would say
artificial there's so many foreigners
there
uh it's uh sort of preserved as a
colonial city
um lots of surprisingly beautiful little
uh courtyards and houses in behind these
uh unassuming houses that appear on the
streets
um there was a festival there of people
from neighboring towns that came and
danced in their indian plumes and
feathers celebrating the conquista
now the reason they celebrate the
conquista is because that's when they
were
introduced to the wonders of
christianity and the virgin mary and so
forth and so on
here in guanajuato it's it's different
it's a a university city it's a
government city it's a tourism city
there are beautiful plazas everywhere
and
they're little
small streets uh cajones that go up the
the hillside
there is music everywhere
in the restaurants the mariachis
my wife and i went on a on a nighttime
walk up these uh narrow streets led by
these troubadours
um
so it's it's a wonderful experience very
relaxing
uh
yet of course it is very crowded
lots of noisy vehicles and buses spewing
their smoke and so forth and so on but
islands of tranquility there
nevertheless
most interesting to learn about mexico
i've been doing some reading trying to
immerse myself
so i've got this book here la idea de
nuestro patrimonio historico e cultural
which is very interesting because it
talks about
the sort of sense of who are the
mexicans what's important what's their
cultural and and
you know
sense of identity where does it come
from because they have their
very rich
pre-colonial history and then they have
the period of colonialism where they
were
developing a culture just as north
americans developed the culture which
brought together i guess the fact of
living in these
geographic circumstances and the spanish
influence and the original
uh native influence and then of course
since independence which was a bloody
event that took 10 years so we saw that
today in the in the museum here alondiga
uh granary converted into first to
prison then a museum
took 10 bloody years and of course they
had the revolution a
100 years later which was another 10
bloody years as
different forces fought each other so
i'm learning about all of that i've got
this other book here which is called
nueva historia minima de mexico because
i try to go over the minima i haven't
got time to read the maxima
and pick up a magazine called what is it
historias in mexico because that gives
me some pictures so i get to see uh what
these people looked like a hundred years
ago and so so have a good time
mexico is
a
a
buenos
a
thank you for listening bye for now